Let’s get ready to learn English with the enchanting, Luna Lovegood!
I’ve loved the Harry Potter film and
book series since I was a child.
Besides the magic and adventure,
what I loved the most was the incredible characters in the story.
And if you’re a fan of the series, then you will
definitely agree that Luna Lovegood is
is without a doubt one of the most
beloved characters. Not only is she quirky,
witty, and wise, but she is also one
of the most unique characters that you will encounter.
In this lesson, you’ll learn tons of great vocabulary while we
look at some of the reasons that make Luna Lovegood so special.
But before we do, if you’d like to understand your
favorite TV series and movies without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles,
then be sure to hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below, so that you never
miss out on any of our new lessons.
Who is your favorite Harry Potter Character? Let us know
down in the comments below, and we might just make a lesson with them!
Do you want to be able to watch absolutely any
movie or TV series in English without needing subtitles?
If understanding the jokes, culture, and
every word are important to you, then our free
3-part masterclass is just what you need
to speak English more confidently and naturally.
Simply sign up now by clicking
up here or down in the description below.
Now let’s do a quick quiz to see how much you’ve learned
by watching without subtitles and answering some questions!
If you enjoyed this lesson and you’d like to
continue learning with Harry Potter,
then be sure to check out our lesson with the recent
Harry Potter reunion! Let’s check out a clip from that!